oh that's a good question this is like a
man this should be taking place in the
Marvel headquarters you know
hey reject Nation so uh we got invited
to do the in-person Press junkie
interview for black panther McConnor
forever however uh due to scheduling at
the time we just couldn't make it it was
just not gonna happen but we were able
to send one of our most reoccurring
guests on the channel Aaron Alexander
and I think he did a terrific job so
thank you Aaron so please leave a like
share support for Aaron because yeah he
did great hey what's up my name is Aaron
I am here with the real rejects I just
wanted to say I love the movie you were
fantastic in it thank you and I think
the way you are able to emote with your
eyes and convey so many emotions is
really impressive I'm an actor myself so
yeah watching is like really master
class I appreciate that thank you I'm
really happy to be here thank you yeah I
know it's been a long day for you so
thank you for taking time
you guys are my first like drunken
interview ever so this is cool nice nice
yeah guys uh yeah so pressure no
pressure no pressure
what do you feel that akoi ultimately
wants as a character and then as an
actor what do you feel that she
ultimately needs I think she definitely
wants you know she wants the prosperity
of her Nation the stability and the
prosperity of her nation and I remember
the first movie The Amazing Ruth Carter
had these beautiful pictures of that
words that inspired how she was seeing
the swordless Nations this gorgeous like
I don't know where she got those
pictures it was just like really cool
ass black people and um I just would you
know I'd have them in my in my trailer
because I was remembering that's who I'm
protecting I'm protecting them so that
they can do their thing in this world
and be cool as black people and not have
to think about tyranny or colonization
or any of those things coming for us you
know so I've got to protect that those
and those their children's children just
like my four mothers did and that sort
of a purpose was very clear to me about
her and so that's definitely what she
wants she wants the preservation and the
prosperity of her Nation above all
things I think
um what she needs uh you know she she
needed to start listening to herself
taking care of herself self-care is
something I don't think koi is very good
at at all she takes care of other things
she doesn't care take care of herself
wow well that was a very beautiful and
expansive answer thank you sure the book
there's a always been a lot with your
character that has kind of been not
shown on screen but there's definitely
like a life to your character what more
would you like to explore or if given
the opportunity to expand upon oh that's
a good question this is like this should
be
taking the Marvel head
Nikki is the person you call
in your time of need she seems to be
that person the speed dial and I love
that about her I guess I'd be curious to
know how she shows up for herself and I
would also like to delve into these
interests we see that she's very much
involved in the world and stuff like
that I would love to see where that
comes from I you know I love to see her
origin story yeah that would be cool
she's a badass she's killing it yeah
she's doing she is she is it's all about
putting your characters I think
understanding where they're rooted where
they're rooted from what's guiding them
but then also what sort of positions and
situations can you put them in that will
allow them to grow be stretched and
challenged so those are the two sides I
would of course would instantly go to
look at a narrative on her yeah as you
as an artist someone who's performing
what do you feel that Nakia ultimately
wants and what do you feel as the person
embodying her that she ultimately needs
oh my God now this that's way too deep
man it's been a long day
Joe
being
the questions I asked myself when I'm
getting into character now I've
forgotten it's a year later yeah I'm an
actor and artist oh my God yeah man this
is a lot I don't know whether I have an
answer for you man
the lasting impact on the world as we
know it and I think she's also really
interested in human unity and in
representing the underdog that is where
her passion lies representing the
underdog and standing up for the unjust
that is something that keeps her up at
night Injustice what was your biggest
takeaway doing this film like what was
the the thing you learned I mean there's
there's an aspect of surrendering and
letting go that you know my character
has to do it was disorienting and and
very you know difficult and challenging
to do it without Chadwick and of course
it was all about honoring him but it was
also very difficult to step back in the
world without him there I'm realizing as
I talk how how much I am like I'm like
like my character and I are parallel but
like you know you want to be in control
and know how to get things done and know
how to do things and then you you
realize um this one you might need to
just let go and she had to do that and I
had to do that what was the most
impactful lesson you took away from the
experience of it for me this movie was a
meditation in staying open-hearted and
being and operating with the generosity
of spirit it's something that I thought
about every single day making these
movies is not a smooth Road at all
there's a lot of changes that happen
along the way that are extremely
uncomfortable for an actor like me who
likes to prepare there's moments when
you really just don't have a choice but
to get the script first thing in the
morning and learn it and show up on set
like 30 minutes later and it is
unnerving but as I was getting ready for
this movie I was thinking about Chadwick
and how he showed up with his A-game all
the time and despite the illness that he
was going through he committed to these
imaginary circumstances like his life
depended on it I watch his movies that
he did in in the last few years of his
life and I I just can't fathom how he
was going through so much personally and
still was able to put all that aside to
play these characters that don't even
exist and so I was thinking about that
and I realized that you know he showed
up to his life and lived it to the
absolute fullest it was a short life but
it was an impactful life and he did so
with such a Grace I mean he led the
Black Panther set
quietly and in his honor I thought to
myself you know I can't sweat the small
stuff I have to show up and enjoy this
experience that he doesn't get to be a
part of and I have to enjoy it for
myself and also to honor him and I'm
very proud of how I went through the
process because I enjoyed every moment
and there were moments when it was
frustrating and I allowed it and I
allowed for it I did what I could and I
just let go of the rest and it was a way
more fluid experience than any other
film that I ever worked on you guys were
featured in the movie prominently and
you guys had a really good roles kind of
being those those Warriors within the
realm of telecon do you guys had the
chance to like really further explore
your characters what would you want to
see with what you guys were were getting
you know we have a lot of chains for
explore or characters because well I
spent one year completely one year
training for playing Amora I I don't
know I have to learn a lot of things
about me about the character I I never
heard before about the comic and so I am
trying to find a little things for
ketchup in the narrative and was amazing
because you need to change your mind for
for play a characters like this it's
like okay you need to learn hold your
breath underwater you need act
underwater it was a
a challenge you know that we all went
through the whole thing together which
makes it very special you know to see
that growth as a as a team because we're
a team as far as uh you know the the
characters you know some people say oh
we're we're the antagonists and you know
I don't I don't see it like that I see
us as a community of people just wanting
a better life wanting to protect our
resources wanting to protect our way of
life and I think you know you can see a
lot of real life echo in our story you
know seeing how we move into the water
in search of a better life for us I
think you can see a lot of that Echo
here within the States you know as
people coming here and searching for
better life yeah you know everything
that we do is about our people
preserving our way of life and hopefully
we could get another opportunity to
experience that yeah I hope so too
because I really liked what you guys
brought you're formidable and yeah I
want to see you guys both explored
because I think there's a lot of
interesting things that were teased
towards the end of the movie that I
don't want to give away but like there's
a lot more to explore with you guys for
sure yeah definitely I'm making this
movie I know this is kind of you guys
are both biggest family guys have done
what was your most impactful thing you
guys took away from the experience of
the movie of making it I mean being
being part of something like this is
just like wow
uh and you know just just grateful to be
here to be part of this you know this
one specifically because it means so
much it's such a it's such a personal
movie for so many people for so many
different reasons that just to be part
of something like this it's uh I'm very
humble by that may this movie bring me a
lot of opportunities for discover what
what I want to do in the future you know
what I need to do for me for for Mabel
for the actress for my career change
everything around yeah it really opened
up like opportunity for you and shows
like the broadening of your horizons for
sure cool you guys you guys are both
killed in the movie I also love your
fits both I'm sure
um yeah thank you guys thank you so much
thank you thank you for being here I
appreciate you and everything that
you've done both here and I've been
watching Walking Dead since I was like a
kid so I appreciate you as a Creator as
an artist I look forward to seeing more
of your work I appreciate that thank you
so much what's your name again Aaron
thank you Aaron I appreciate that take
care all the best to you
and uh I guess the last question I got
for you I'm sorry that is our time oh
that is
the wrap up you got the wrap up
[Music]